Oh
some people called it the greatest love
story of the 20th century the king who
gave up his throne for the woman he
loved how do you find if you need to
Simpson I'm always cold maybe need
someone to keep you warm
isn't that what husbands are for
can you try to seduce me is it working
I'm sure the rumors aren't true your
majesty watch her watch this he's well
the serious about what do you mean
serious
she's a marriage boy I have never known
one in person so utterly foolish bar
another as he was by her
I read that you kept a collection of
letters would it be possible for me to
look at them I don't generally show them
to anyone I think it's important to tell
the story from her point of view
happy birthday we sweet well that's an
Edward silly what is anything with Duke
and Duchess little girls love fairy
tales how do you know they lived happily
ever after
His Royal Highness sir is calling from
Paris you know you'll give in if you
speak to him he's my brother the last
thing you need is your brother dashing
around England with that horrible am i
busy your family will never stand for it
the Prime Minister won't stand for it
then I'll give up the throne I will be
the most despised woman in the world he
seems to have made his bed doesn't he I
have found it impossible to discharge my
duties as King without to help and
support of the woman I love the whole
world turned against her but she never
backed down
you have no idea how hard it is telling
about the greatest ruins of the century
you